you will love ark because ark you can go
what are you laughing at
you can go go down water you can go deep
there's caves
it's really it's arc it's uh monica is
arc without the poop
[Laughter]
specifically
to be fair name another crafting game
where you can poop in
other than ark
is there any
is there any i think it's it might only
be really famous for pooping it really
is
just google arkansas why are you are you
sure arc is famous for pooping or are
you trying to make it famous are you
trying to make your face google it right
now ark poop why is
why is pooping in the game what does
that help with
because you can use it for like to like
manure and stuff
like crafting materials
poop too
somewhere right
i've just seen compilations of v tubers
reacting to dinosaurs pooping in ark and
they just like lose their mind what
compilation yeah shut up because there's
a shot of course it is oh my god because
there's so
many who play arc and they all like lose
their mind whenever they see
when they when they learn you can poop
in the game and these little laughs
they're awesome okay i will link you the
video
it's just about our
poop machine dino and farming essential
like what yeah cause you can use the
poop as like manure to like grow crops
in the game i'm pretty sure and there's
a dinosaur that that
only
exists for pooping
my entire existence is poop yeah
you know you know that twitter account
which is just you can pet the dog which
is like different games and tell you if
you compare the dog can you poop in the
game
is that poop in this game
no you cannot poop in the legend of
zelda
it's just like all of them except for
rock yeah so other dinosaurs actually
scary in ark or
does that even interest you to begin
with you can tame them you can tame
donna you can tame them oh damn and you
can you can go to caves with them they
can fight for you
they can live with you that sounds cool
see that sounds pretty damn epic can you
do that in subnautica
no you can you can have like a little
fish tank where you like raise your own
fish but that's pretty much it all right
like
you can tame like a dolphin
in conan exiles you can tame human
[Music]
isn't there a word
i was like i'm pretty sure you can do
that in real life as well i don't think
you should but you know that's how they
sell didn't we abolish that
that's how they sell slavery in the
modern day it's taming like
no it's taming yeah
i can't believe reality ripped off kind
of thing so i was like
with a stick
hit their heads really hard like um five
or six times um knock them out and then
chain it to some
i don't know that
something
would make it like
labor it's so random that you put
current exiles that that game was big
like a few years back
does anyone still play coding in exiles
i do
is it still big why'd you call her out
like that man i'm sorry i just i don't
know anyone else who plays quite an xr
still that is the only one i remember
there was like drama between youtubers
when one of them like destroyed the
other's base or something and it
genuinely caused like drama they
actually had a falling out because you
could destroy each other's base in the
game did that also happen in like rust
as well i think so oh yeah there was
like drama around that as well can you
do that on arc as well yeah you can do
that
yeah
griefing is i think yeah
toxic is there like an etiquette to the
game or normally i think there is
etiquette in games like that
and if someone like [ __ ] everything up
you're like he's not allowed on servers
again yeah and just banned him from the
circle he's banned yeah i imagine i
imagine this is like the perfect
uh concoction for that [ __ ] south
park warcraft episode where there's just
one guy killing everyone right classic
pretty much